do you have a philosophy of math so for
example there's platonism and formalism
if anything i would be an ultra fine
artist
so
but it's much more graded than that
so you know there is a hierarchy
of
um
of
complexities of things or sizes
of things in mathematics
so
you know people in set theory and logic
and you know talk about
large cardinal axioms
uh and
uh
then there are
parts of mathematics that have to do
with uncountable or
bigger than uncountable
and then there are infinite parts and
then there are just infinite without
being uncountable right and just
countable say and then there are parts
of mathematics that are um
finite but
huge uh so you know ramsey theory
uh
you have uh
you know
you prove that if a graph is large
enough then it has properties certain
properties but large enough means really
really really really really really
really really huge bigger than the
number of atoms in the universe
and then there are
uh
you know parts of mathematics
uh
that happens where uh the numbers
are uh between 10 to the 6
and 10 to the 12 i don't know what a
computer can do in a fraction of a
second to what a computer can do in an
hour
okay and you know maybe you can go a
little bit beyond to 10 to the 16 i
don't know 10 to the 15. i don't know
okay
so there is this whole grading
and to me
the bigger things
are the less important they are
uh
and
uh because they're farther away from our
everyday experience
so they may have philosophical value and
some of them do
so i don't want to
completely say
anything about large cardinals is not
interesting
or anything about infinity is not
interesting
but the bar is higher
for something that genuinely use uses
infinity
to be interesting
the bar is higher
than if the thing is
uh
in this in the range of sizes
that we can actually hold in our hands
so that's what i mean by an ultra finite
test i mean
sort of the
or or so this is a form so an ultra
finalities would say the only numbers
that exist are the numbers i could count
to
and maybe by uh
extension that my computer could count
to so maybe my computer can count up to
this number but 10 to the 100 does not
exist in some sense because my computer
will never be able to count there
okay we'll never be able to get there
so
i'm not an extreme i would say sometimes
there is value to this one too
and sometimes there is even value to
infinity and sometimes there is even
value to the bigger form of infinity but
the bar has to be higher
uh the the the the philosophical value
bar has to be higher
the bigger the the size is
these things are always interesting
these things are interesting only on
special circumstances